je compte présentement avec le web du
gouvernement libéral en effet le viet la
soirée donc 2 3 1 c'est un cauchemar
social à bientôt courir le triathlon une
piqûre qu est ce que tu a nui au travail
du piquet de s'entraîner autant
non je trouve qu'en juillet les horaires
et la politique mais il ya la vie
également ses fans viennent vous êtes le
whip du gouvernement
c'est ce que faisait fringante de oued
au début de la série house of cards mais
c'est quoi ça fait une des fonctions
qu'on voit à 4,52 blood fait au début de
our carte qui est exactement la même
c'est de s'assurer la majorité des votes
de chaussures de luxe nombre de records
le poète et des traces malien disco
c'était oui c'est le mot d'esprit de mes
yeux pas vraiment de discipline comme on
peut voir modifier notre annonce
réprimandé le ballon trop clean d'une
femme meurt un mois chez oudart noir
c'est beaucoup plus s'assurer que les
gens sont au bon endroit au bon moment
je suis allé à la rencontre jouée
ça c'est un processus qui est
confidentiel c'est tellement de
différences qui étaient étaient assez
durs et ici il ya des huit dans chacun
des partis carole poirier au véhicule et
donald martel à la carte qui est ce que
vous travaillez ensemble dans le cadre
d'un énorme ménages que ce soit les
dossiers principalement de vous du
bureau de l'assemblée nationale ont de
l'assemblée sonnac et une bonne
cinquantaine alors que vous vous
accrochez défaut c'est rare parce qu'on
te dit aussi ce soit des dossiers
apolitique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]